[Musique]
ensuite on passe à la grande affaire de
la semaine
lardy view
[Musique]
et axa tout frais bonsoir d'abord fait
un plaisir de vous recevoir c'est la
première fois que je vous reçois dans
l'une de mes émissions c'est comme un
premier rendez vous buvez quoi là c'est
de l'eau fraîche de l'eau fraîche vous
êtes dit quoi dans le taxi merde je vais
devoir dire à quel âge je me suis fait
violer par un iman en syrie
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
je me suis dit que j'étais très content
de venir parce que je vous ai regardé
très très souvent à la télé et c'est un
petit ça me fait un petit effet un petit
choc d'être avec vous ça fait très
plaisir c'est comme moi le jour où je
ferais drucker
tu manges la file sauve moi alors riaz
vous êtes l'auteur de nombreuses bd à
succès la vie secrète des jeunes publié
d'abord dans charlie hebdo au pascal
brutal les cahiers d'esther et bien sûr
la râpe du futur votre enfant sont bd
qui vous a valu de nombreux prix et qui
s'est vendu pratiquement à 2 millions
d'exemplaires mais est également
cinéaste avec les beaux gosses et jacky
au royaume des filles bd ou signer tout
part toujours du dessin en tout cas fait
gaffe quand même parce que c'est que
dessinateur aujourd'hui c'est un métier
à risque un petit peu comme patron de
bistrot à marseille où ou crs le samedi
si dans mon com extrait bien fait des
bulles iazev day
et des pêches ben ari a rejeté le 5 mai
1978 d'une mère bretonne et d'un père
syrien c'est lui qui a gagné pour le
prénom un même temps gwenaëlle sattouf
serait était bizarre donc c'est mieux
que ce soit rien qu'en alors vous après
nommé ryad mais quand on voit cette
photo vous avez vraiment une tête de
petit breton 1 quand vous étiez go
soutien petit breton d'ailleurs vos
enfants sont grands oui bah oui tout à
fait comme quoi alors cette photo a été
prise en libye vous avez habité pendant
votre jeunesse votre père abdel razaq
était enseignant ici d'une famille très
pauvre il était un brillant élève il
avait obtenu une bourse pour étudier en
france il a finit quand même par
décrocher un doctorat d'histoire à la
sorbonne tout affaibli alors resto u de
la sorbonne notre père rencontrer votre
mère paiement tin oo oui en fait mon
père parlait très très mal français
c'est un énorme dragueur et donc il le
fils y est quand même pas mal dans les
restos u est en fait il a commencé à
draguer la copine de ma mère est en fait
il lui a proposé un rendez-vous il
paraîtrait my way comment tu t'appelles
et tout est dit j'ai pas normal j'ai pas
demain c'est joli ça comme nom et il dit
à ma mère et toi comment tu t'appelles
dit comme elle comme elle c'est joli
et donc et
rendez vous il demande un rendez-vous à
la copine de ma mère et ma mère lui dit
non non mais laisse tomber en fait il
est collé à fond a eu 10 des corps
demain 19h place de l'opéra et sk soute
les deux est en fait elle pensait le
planter mais ma mère a eu pitié de lui
et elle est allée au rang des lames et
voilà je suis là c'est juste là on est
alors en 1982 alors qu'on propose à
leurs pairs d'enseigner à oxford il
choisit la libye ensuite vous poserez
vos valises en syrie près de homs et
vous dites mon père était un
nationaliste arabe il était pour sortir
le monde arabe de la servitude et
voulaient participer à l'éducation du
monde arabe en fait c'est un admirateur
de nasser il était dans le panarabisme
il était bassiste d'une certaine façon
après les islamismes au départ ils
étaient laïques bassiste comme tous ces
dictateurs du moyen orient il était
fasciné par saddam hussein oui c'était
sa grande sa grande idole en fait parce
que déjà saddam hussein étaient sunnites
comme lui ouais il adorait aussi à phase
el assad mais c'était pas comme il était
à la weed s'était pas mais saddam
hussein en fait ils pensaient avoir un
destin comme comme saddam hussein salem
hussein et d'un petit village misérables
et s'étaient enfuis ensuite il avait il
avait rejoint son nom tu lui qui lui
avait appris à lire et à écrire en fait
des années plus tard il avait fini par
faire un coup d'état mon père pensait
qu'il aurait un un destin exactement
semblables il rêvait de faire des coups
détails mais quand saddam hussein a été
arrêté il était très humilié votre place
c'est vrai qu'en fait ils et voilà il
était c'était quelqu'un d'assez brutale
aussi tard comme saddam hussein qui
avait fait progresser l'irak de manière
incroyable y avait conflit des routes il
avait eu un prix de l'unesco pour
l'alphabétisation de son pays ils
exécutaient ses opposants à tour de bras
mon père est pensée comme ça votre père
était d'extrême droite on peut le dire
oui moi je pense qu'il on peut vraiment
dire qu'il est extrêmement il admirait
pas seulement saddam hussein il adorait
pinochet lebel est le pen il pensait que
c'était le plus grand homme politique
française telle homologues
dans tous les cas votre père et voulait
que vous aviez à l'école il vous dit tu
vas à l'école parce que l'arabe du futur
lui va à l'école ce qu'a donnée le le
titre d'oeuvre sévèrement exactement
bande dessinée alors vous étudié le
coran mais vous faites semblant de prier
vous y croyez pas du tout il voulait à
la fois que je grandisse dans les mêmes
conditions qui avaient été les siennes
c'est dans une école de village avec des
enfants très religieux etc et en même
temps ils exigeaient rain man en disant
je suis un moderne tu fais ce que tu
veux et cetera je ne force pas il y
avait ces deux ces deux choses qui se
mélangent et votre mère est blanche il
vous êtes un peu le blondinet à l'école
et les mômes se moque de vous quoi sont
hyper racistes avec vous en fait ce qui
se passait quand vous avez pu le voir
sur la photo c'est pas seulement que
j'étais blond c'est que j'étais
extrêmement beau et donc
comme on déteste les baux en génère
souvent non seulement j'étais beau en
plus j'étais extrêmement lèche cul à
l'école j'étais désiré des ultras bonnes
notes j'étais tout le temps avec
l'épreuve j'étais un super puma galère
pour les maîtresses passait l'été leurs
mains dans mes cheveux blonds passé en
effet il m'aimait pas trop je n'avais
pas beaucoup d'amis mais c'est vrai
alors comme vous n'avez pas d'amis vous
évadez vous commencé à dessiner ce qui
n'est pas très bien vu en syrie et vous
lisez tintin que votre grand mère
bretonne vous envoie zaza c'est ça c'est
exactement ça c'est comme ça tout a
commencé parce qu'en fait il n'y avait
pas de vivre dans le village où on
habite elle pas de livres en arabe du
tout même ma mère mon père ne lisez pas
les seuls livres qui avait s'était mêlé
tintin de ma grand mère bretonne donc
j'ai appris à lire le français en lisant
tintin pas mal à à l'âge de 11 ans vous
rentrez en france donc avec votre mère
et le retour est aussi violent que la
vie en syrie parce que ça rien à voir
évidemment avec la société que vous
connaissez est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué d'être breton en syrie ou
arabe en bretagne en france en fait j'ai
jamais souffert vraiment de racisme ou
de ou de strass isation si ce n'est le
fait que mon nom était ridicule mais on
a d'autres pour des noms des mines mais
voilà c'est vrai quand on sait
actuellement en classe ça tout le monde
souhaite en faire
c'est vrai c'était pas c'était pas il y
avait il y avait une moindre
considération que je dirai en face on
faisait moins tant sur un mois alors
exemple de choc culturel vous avez pas
comment aborder une fille parce qu'on
s'y risquer un petit peu interdits et
quand une fille tombe amoureuse de vous
elle vous fait des avances vous
n'arrivez pas à l'embrasser et elle
raconte à tout le monde que vous êtes
impuissant j'étais partagé entre deux
pôles si j'avais mon père qui devenait
de plus en plus traditionalistes et
n'arrêtait pas de me répéter que les
femmes était le diable et qu'il fallait
pas leur parler et qu'il fallait pas les
regarder qu'il fallait se marier plus
tard ceux là et mon grand père brottier
du était ultra obsédé sexuel avait
extrêmement peur que vous soyez au mot
et chaumont était très homophobe et donc
dès qu'on marche un la ruine disait en
rien celle là tu as vu mon jeu c'était
un an les hormones peut-être pas
commencer à fonctionner
aucun effet si c'est ça la regarde et je
voi alors quand on est comme ça coincé
entre deux pôles
c'était difficile de choisir ce que si
on ne sait si c'est 1 par rapport à
l'autre forcément j'avais donc je vois
que ça c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
choisi une identité
qui n'existait pas dans ma famille en
fait ni du côté syrien ni du côté breton
c'est l'identité des gens qui font des
livres et qui raconte des histoires et
j'ai choisi ce peuple là est ce que
votre grand père vous emmener faire du
naturisme
thierry vous voulez trop savoir la suite
de la
et je me sens vous attendent extrêmement
bons lecteurs pour la suite
tant qu'un jean marie roy re bonsoir
donc jean marie voire de l'académie
française aurais-je dû dire alors je
vais rater cinq fois votre bac de la
voir votre premier roman a été refusée
par très éditeurs ssii ou présenté cinq
fois l'académie avant d'être élu est ce
qu'avec les femmes c'est pareil
c'est exactement pareil et je vais vous
faire une confidence entre loups
je pensais que l'académie ça a aidé un
peu oui à draguer oui et un soir dîner
avec une très jolie fille et j'avançais
beaucoup d'arguments je le prix renaudot
j'ai eu le prix interallié je suis d'un
dernier à médard nice ont fait tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient tout ce qui pouvait
vraiment l flatteur et ça ne marchait
pas
le marché va alors à la fin
pour la décidé jeudi et puis vous savez
je suis à l'académie française tiens je
ne savais pas vous étiez si vieux
j'ai lu que luc ferry n'a pas été élu à
l'académie c'était bien la peine mon
cher luc de ne pas venir dans cette
émission pendant une saison par peur de
faire une boulette qui t'aurait écouter
l'académie
vous avez été pour ou contre ferry
moi je suis pour tous les candidats ah
oui oui je suis pour tous les candidats
parce que je suis resté à candidats
comme je suis resté le type qui échoue
et aux baoulé c'est vrai qu'ils vous
voyez chez libre refusée par les
éditeurs j'ai le sentiment d'être du
côté des perdants du côté des vaincus et
toute ma vie quand je crée un nouveau
livre j'ai l'impression que c'est le
premier livre vous savez je trouve qu'il
faut que les candidats sage on va leur
donner un conseil certainement beaucoup
qui le découvrait il faut qu'ils sachent
d'une part que c'est pas du monde est
battue battu quatre fois et victor hugo
cie et d'euros et puis ensuite qu'il
faut insister parce que c'est comme de
l'entrée dans les marines et on veut on
veut voir si les types yann lozano voilà
moi j'ai tenu le coup alors
y'a plein de postes vacants à l'académie
alors il ya sollers évidemment tout le
monde pense à solers me l'a dit mais
pourquoi céder à cette comédie sociale
aucun des écrivains que j'admire net à
l'académie donc sollers déjà lui veut
pas y aller à paris c'est sympa c'est
moins sympa non
il avait écrit un livre sur la nature et
des exceptions où les gens qu'il
admirait c'était l'autre à mons et des
gens vraiment qu'il était mort à 25 ans
il a une conception des poètes maudits
c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent être moulés il
y en a eu très peu à la caméra mais
quasiment pas la grève et verlaine a usé
on voit et baudelaire lui a dit vaudrait
mieux vous retirer donc si on a une
conception de la vie de la littérature
qui est soulevée lors east en fait voilà
subversives c'est vrai que là qu'elle
est lui pas fait pour ça alors welbeck
20 ans et qu'il peut rentrer l'académie
française
écoutez je
l'écoutais qu'il aurait pu rentrer moi
je dirais je crois que l'académie c'est
quand même aussi
incarner le grand écrivain
possible donc dans lesquels les français
se reconnaissent une certaine idée de la
france en fait c'est une certaine idée
la manche on peut dire que c'est la voix
de la france baisse quand même ça va
quand même moi j'aime beaucoup où el bec
comme écrivain ouais mais j'aime
beaucoup aussi ces lignes comme et que
j'aurai pas voter pour ses leaders et
annie hamel tout après doit pas d'accord
quand le figaro fait sa une sur welbeck
ça doit vous gêner quand même c'est à
dire que je trouve
que ça mérite un débat welbeck et voyez
la différence avec jean d'ormesson c'est
que jean d'ormesson la grand mère peut
offrir à son petit fils un livre dedans
me sont pour un première communion je
vois pas la grand mère qu'elle gromaire
offrirait un livre de houellebecq où on
parle quand même de deux fellations
profil j'ai rien contre la fellation la
zoophilie je m'arrête
alors est-ce que berlin allait lui a une
chance d'entrer un jour à l'académie oui
mais il faut qu'ils osent et je crains
que bien la rue halévy que j'aime
beaucoup que la très vieille amie eh
bien je crois que il n'a pas envie les
perdants ouais c'est sa différence avec
moi moi je suis d'aller au devant de
l'échec toute ma vie et viale mans je
trouve ça formidable d'être du côté
bernois parce qu'on en fait ce sentiment
de l'échec
c'est ce qui doit guider tous les
écrivains voyez une question que je me
posais sur la cades évidence il ya quand
même cinq femmes pour 31 hommes est-ce
que ça suffit pour faire à manger alors
alors déjà il ya eu une révolution c'est
que grâce un bon gros son il ya eu
l'élection de marguerite yourcenar c'est
vrai que et puis il ya quand même une
femme qui est secrétaire perpétuelle oui
car d'encausse rango c'est quand même
c'est elle qui dirige 12
michel serrault bonsoir bonsoir nous
seuls serres de l'académie française
aurais-je dû dire et vous en plus d'être
réellement immortel vous avez 88 ans
michel oui
vous êtes l'homme de 88 ans le plus
jeune du monde finalement
c'est ce qu'on dit mais je cache ou bien
mon jeu oui c'est à dire oui je classe
en blog est trop jeune mais mais ce
n'est pas vraiment d'accord peinture
donc je me dis à se créer c'est pas vrai
heureusement vous est immortel parce que
à l'académie on trouve personne pour
remplacer les disparus vous prendriez
kivu luc ferry par exemple il s'est
présenté il n'a pas été ému il a voté
pour ou contre
l'ivho son secret mon cher d'accord
alors sinon mes 10 ou noir oui ciel
houellebecq par exemple penser qu'ils
méritent d'être à l'académie française
je vais voter bien qu'ils viennent louis
oui d'accord très bien emmanuel carrère
d'encausse oui non il ya déjà sa mère
qui est là et voilà ce que secrétaire
perpétuel problèmes de famille avec un
semblant pour lui je n'entends pas me
les affaires de famille est vrai est ce
que est ce que vous savez qui est
frédéric beigbeder par exemple oui bien
sûr est ce que vous pensez qu'il
pourrait peut-être un jour entrer à
l'académie française oui tout le monde
pour entrer le quelqu'un y compris vous
mon cher bon
sinon il reste il s line renaud bon line
renaud ecalle 07 c'est pas gagné oui ou
alors en robot est ce qu'un jour vous
pensez qu'il y aura un robot avec les
micros 16 mai digest manière nous sommes
tous des robots mais vous savez donc par
exemple comment maquiller ouais on m'a
mis des choses il faut l'écouter je suis
déjà un petit roquet voilà
le mois dernier vous avez fait la
couverture du magazine le point avec ce
titre la femme qui fait peur aux
islamistes et pas l inverse et pourtant
si vous n'avez pas d'armes isolé là dans
une pièce et fracassé lui le crâne avec
une pierre tranchées lui la gorge et
brûler sa maison ou encore j'ai une
folle envie de lui crever les yeux avec
un pic à glace mais je pense que je vais
les gorges et sa phrase à faire tout ça
tout ça parce que vous ne voulez pas que
vos amis de charlie hebdo soit mort pour
rien parce qu'au pays des lumières le
droit au blasphème est un bien sacré
merci de défendre le 18e tchèque
français et bien c'est triste de se dire
qu'on en est là en 2019
fondre l'héritage des lumières à
défendre les valeurs fondamentales qui
sont l'adn de la république française
qui sont notre devise liberté égalité
fraternité
et puis le socle laïque de l'état
français la laïcité c'est ce n'est pas
une opinion ce n'est pas un dogme c'est
tout simplement la liberté d'avoir une
opinion alors visite il faut que l'islam
se soumettent à la critique qu'il se
soumette à l'humour qu'il se soumette
aux lois de la république qu'ils se
soumettent au droit français vous pensez
que c'était tanaki mais il se trouve que
nous faisons face à des à des discours à
des revendications
militante parfois un militantisme très
agressif qui consiste à vouloir nous
faire accepter son couvert de tolérance
d'acceptation de l'autre non pas des
individus différents mais les idéologies
dont il se revendique à la république
française est une république qui
embrasse tous les individus mais pas les
idéologies forcément surtout quand elles
sont contraires à nos valeurs en fait
dire qu'on devrait pouvoir critiquer
l'islam c'est déjà le critiquer pour eux
non bah oui vous avez vu ce passage
vidéo là qui m'a valu des menaces de
mort je disais simplement que l'islam
devait se soumettre à la critique je
sais que ce combat là n'est pas un
détail c'est un combat qui trace la
frontière en vraiment rentrer la
civilisation et la barbarie alors vous
vous dite persuadée que si les médias en
france avaient tous publié les
caricatures de mahomet leurs 11 janvier
2015 l'histoire aurait été différente
tout à fait je pense que si tous les
journaux de france et de navarre et du
reste de monde d'ailleurs avait publié
les caricatures des là dès la première
affaire des caricatures en 2006 qu'est
ce qu'ils auraient fait l'aller les
terroristes et aurait exterminé tous les
journalistes toutes les rédactions du
monde ce n'était pas possible une
victoire 10 maquillé en respect de la
religion tout à fait parce que beaucoup
de journaux on justifiait finalement
leur peur des attentats qui est une part
légitime
avoir peur
ne nous exonère pas d'un certain devoir
de courage surtout quand on est
journaliste parce que quand on est
journaliste nous avons le devoir de
crever les abcès de la société nous
avons le devoir de mettre la lumière sur
les sur les zones nombre et les journaux
qui à l'époque avait dit à nous ne
faisons pas parce que nous respectons
l'islam ou les musulmans ou je ne sais
plus ce qu'ils avaient dit en réalité
sous-entendait que charlie ne respectait
pas et que donc finalement
quelque part cet attentat était
justifiée
[Musique]
d
alors vous résister vaillamment le
problème c'est que bientôt en france il
faudra choisir entre sa liberté
d'expression et sa liberté de vivre sans
gardes du corps après roberto saviano et
philippe val vous êtes la troisième
personne sous protection policière que
je reçois cette saison ça fait beaucoup
quand même dans un pays comme la france
vous dites quand ça allait mal
ce sont les flics qui m'ont sauvé mais
oui j'ai été mise sous protection le 8
janvier 2015 je me ramasse évidemment à
la petite cuillère j'avais des
conditions de vie qui était extrêmement
difficile et à ce moment là évidemment
comme comme beaucoup de mes collègues
qui avaient survécu nous avons atterri
chez les psy nous avons pris des
anxiolytiques des antidépresseurs ça
n'allait pas et ce sont ces la présence
bienveillante professionnels de mes
officiers de sécurité qui m'a contrainte
à me rattacher à la vie contrainte à me
à respecter des horaires parfois ils se
sont alors que ce n'est pas leur travail
parfois ils se sont fait de savoir si
j'avais mangé ou pas et donc grâce à eux
grâce à cette présence scène j'ai pu
surmonter
les premières semaines de deuil
c'est bizarre quand même d'être
accompagné par des gens qui sont là pour
vous empêcher de mourir et qui
pourraient mourir en vous protégeant
quand même une relation complexe c'est
une relation assez atypique parce que ce
sont fondamentalement des inconnus des
gens que l'on vous voit mais qui sont là
pour mourir éventuellement avec vous
donc sacrés comme ça crée un lien de
sang et les attentats de charlie m'ont
fait découvrir que les liens de sang
entre les personnes pouvaient se faire
autrement qu'en étant issus de la même
fratrie par exemple avec mes collègues
de charniers d'eau eh bien nous avons
entre nous aujourd'hui le lien de sang
de le sens des nôtres qui a coulé et qui
nous lient d'une façon indéfectible vous
êtes toujours là
[Musique]
dans la gauche a trahis depuis longtemps
le combat du progressisme et de la
laïcité
mais le 7 janvier le jour de
l'anniversaire de charlie emmanuel
macron a reçu le cfcm très maladroit
pour le moins nous avons une gauche qui
était le tenant historiques du combat du
progressisme de l'anticléricalisme
elle a complètement trahi ces valeurs là
elle a même trahi karl marx qui a
toujours dit que la religion était
l'opium du peuple aujourd'hui on observe
une gauche islamophile pour renverser le
mot islamophobie et sur le plan
électoral là tout le monde a trahi c'est
à dire que les compromissions
électoralistes
l'adage une mosquée trois mandats les
baux emphytéotiques les terrains à north
aux associations cultuelles islamistes
ou construire des mosquées ça et bien la
gauche et la droite sont toutes les deux
mouiller et pourtant vite vous
l'islamisme a déjà perdu contrairement
au jeune français d'origine musulmane
les jeunes des pays musulmans dit vous
sont de plus en plus apte est donc temps
que l'obscurantisme s'empare de l'europe
l'athéisme surgi dans les pays arabes
c'est là que j'en veux aux dirigeants de
ce pays les dirigeants de ce pays n'ont
pas compris que la plus belle prise de
l'islam politique
ça sera l'europe et notamment la france
aujourd'hui les la nébuleuse islamiste
international a très bien compris que
les pays musulmans moi c'est un peu
fichu puis de toute façon ce ne sont pas
des démocraties ils sont à la merci des
régimes sur place tandis qu'en europe eh
bien ils détournent les les droits
humains les valeurs démocratiques et les
droits que nous avons dans ces pays là à
leur propre
service à leur propre profit et nos
dirigeants malheureusement ne s'en
rendent pas compte et laisse proliférer
un islamisme militant qui fait des
ravages qui fait des dégâts dans toute
une partie de la société est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'il ya une salle hafiz ation
des musulmans de france et bien
lorsqu'on lit les statistiques on ne
peut que s'inquiéter lorsqu'on lit par
exemple que 28 % des jeunes et ceux de
l'islam considère que la charia est
supérieure aux lois de la république on
a toutes les raisons de s'inquiéter
lorsqu'on lit les rapports des
renseignements généraux qui nous raconte
par exemple ce qui se passe dans les
classes lorsqu'on voit les les
revendications communautaristes de plus
en plus nombreuses de plus en plus
stupide aussi de plus en plus agressive
on a toutes les raisons de s'inquiéter
finalement et de se dire où est
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est finalement
la nation française c'est la communauté
nationale c'est lé droit que nous avons
en france c'est la liberté dont nous
jouissons dans ce pays et qui pour moi
est nettement plus crucial plus
importante que la liberté de certains
le choix de certains d'observer des lots
des bondieuseries auquel il croit quand
le président macron dernièrement parle
de ces cessions est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a compris enfin
j'espère qu'il a compris j'espère qu'il
a compris et j'ai bon espoir parce qu'il
a par exemple renoncer à la modification
qui était prévue de la loi de 1905 parce
que je pense qu'il a compris qu'il
aurait ouvert la une boîte de pandore
dont seraient sortis des monstres
ingérable ceci étant dit maintenant il
reste ce chantier de restructuration de
réorganisation de ce qu'ils appellent
l'islam de france je m'insurge
d'ailleurs contre ce terme parce que
pour moi il n'ya pas d'islam de france
il ya un islam en france pas plus qu'il
ya un christianisme 2 france - judaïsme
de france donc lorsqu'on voit ce projet
de réorganisation de l'islam en france
on voit que les les propositions qui
sont faites à l'exécutif sont gangrénés
de haut en bas par la présence de l'ue
aux nefs qui s'appelle maintenant
musulmans de france donc des frères
musulmans les frères musulmans qui je le
rappelle sont interdits dans et pays
comme les émirats par exemple en france
saison pour interlocuteur macron
castaner tout va bien et personne ne
s'en offusque
une dernière chose là j'y repense j'en
parle à ma femme un instant c'est la
question colombo
[Musique]
zineb si c'était à refaire vous lancer
dans ce combat contre les islamistes
est ce que vous le referiez
si c'était à refaire je serais même
peut-être aller plus loin
vous savez que qu'au moment où il ya eu
les attentats de charlie où on avait
pour projet pour rêve avec chars d'aller
rejoindre les femmes peshmergas kurdes
qui se battait contre dèche chose que je
n'ai jamais pu faire il ya eu les
attentats ensuite j'ai eu une petite
fille mais je pense que si c'était à
refaire je le ferai avec la même verve
la même véhémence et peut-être avec
beaucoup plus de 2 comment dire beaucoup
plus d'énergie
votre relation avec emmanuel macron
alors c'est un peu richman pour man
c'est à dire que vous naissez tous les
deux à amiens vous êtes scolarisés à la
providence pour en même temps
établissements catholiques jésuites
c'est là où emmanuel macron raconterai
belgique macron il avait 15 ans avait 39
alors l'un à tous l'autre à rien comment
ça va se finir ce film j'en sais rien
non mais d'abord moi je me dis que j'ai
écris pas comme ça quand même moi j'ai
j'appartiens la classe intermédiaire mes
parents m'ont donné les moyens d'avoir
une éducation je sais tout ce que je
dois à plein de gens et jamais je dirais
que je me suis fait tout seul et c'est à
linverse là pour le coup des manuels
macron acquis quand même la vie offert
plein de chance qu'ils qui a eut
bénéficié le tas de rencontres y compris
des rencontres avec des milliardaires
qui lui ont dressé des ponts d'or pour
qu'ils puissent mener campagne et ainsi
de suite et qui vient dire à la fin que
bon si j'étais chômeur je me
débrouillerai tout seul mais il est pas
chômeur il l'a pas été c'est parce que
ça veut dire et il les rencontre pas
donc je dirais que plus tôt
là on nous voit à l'image n'est pas sûr
qu'à ce moment là il ya tant de
différences y en a un qui est plutôt
replié sur lui même et l'autre qui est
applaudi en permanence tant qu' il est
comblé plein de talent et tant mieux
pour lui mais après il ya des choix je
pense que la classe intermédiaire c'est
la classe qui est un choix on lui
fournit des armes les armes qui sont de
larmes de l'éducation de la culture
maintenant c'est au service de qui on
l'aimait et moi je sais que j'ai fait le
choix de m
mon savoir méconnaissance mes lectures
ma capacité à écrire à faire des films
au service des gens et je considère
qu'ils emmanuel macron depuis vingt ans
les a mis au service de l'argent il n'a
pas jamais dragué vaccin à l'école de la
providence lauragais ma soeur il n'y
avait jamais de rigueur
alors dans un livre publié aux arènes
qui s'appelle ce pays que tu ne connais
pas qui excellent d'ailleurs à vous
dites entendent macro quand même votre
tête ne me revient pas vos mines pour
catalogue des 3 suisses voteraient
régulier le nez droit la police la
mâchoire carrée c'est physique c'est
viscéral moi je crois que d'abord moi
j'écris un livre ce pas comme un
politique qui se demande s'il va gagner
3 % avec ça j'écris je fais un film
comme cinéaste avec gilles perret jeu
j'écris un livre comme écrivain et un
écrivain qu'est ce qu'il fait il propose
des portraits de jeunes ont égalé par
exemple via le portrait de j'oublierai
ya même mon autoportrait qui n'est guère
flatteur non plus on ne souligne pas
quand on lit le bouquin mais voilà donc
je propose des portraits évidemment avec
une subjectivité qui effaça ça ça veut
dire que emmanuel macron évidemment ils
portent quelque chose d'une classe dès
que son inconscient parlent ces gens qui
ne sont rien vous n'avez qu'à traverser
la rue dès qu'on appuie sur le bouton il
ya son inconscient qui se met à glisser
et vous savez notre physique ils portent
quelque chose de la classe à laquelle
nous appartenons la manière dont on
bouge la manière dont on se levait pas
voyager donc je en effet il ya des
traits de classe dans le portel emmanuel
macron qui incarne quelque part une
espèce de l'impression de voir débarquer
le super drh de la france alors vous
avez été extrêmement inquiet richard
ferrand déjà taxé
d'antisémitisme parce que vous parlez
toujours ma banque rothschild en parlant
de maquereaux bon moi j'ai passé un
paquet d'années sur bernard arnault qui
est un patron catholique du nord là je
consacre un livre à emmanuel macron qui
est passé par une école jésuites et qui
a choisi de se faire baptiser j'ai passé
des années à attaquer par exemple bnp
paribas parce que je considère que c'est
le ministère occulte l'économie et
notamment michel pébereau patron
catholique jeune homme dont le livre le
collège des bernardins qui offrent
arrêts saut à emmanuel macron et donc
qui est catholique aussi j'ai rien
contre les catholiques c'est juste pour
dire que je fais tout ça et quand on
mange eu le droit aussi de dire banque
rothschild commission attali parce que
ce sont des vies dans points de passage
ou aussi il a construit du réseau quelle
est ma lecture de la société on peut la
trouver simpliste on peut la trouver
sectaire on peut la trouver manichéenne
c'est une lecture de classe j'ai une
lecture de classe et quand je dis
banquiers rothschild moi ce que je
retiens surtout ses banquiers voilà
qu'est ce qui va se passer là parce
qu'apparemment il sait pas trop quoi
dire là emmanuel macron j'en sais rien
je suis pas prophète je suis pas dans sa
tête je sais pas moi je sais ce que je
ferai à sa place mais je ne suis pas
mâcon moi ce que je ferai mais j avais
pas besoin d'attendre et d'essayer de
noyer le poisson comme ça je lis les
demandes d'aidés gilet jaune qui
reviennent je vois une demande sociale
tva à zéro pour cent sur les produits de
première nécessité je vois une demande
fiscale rang l'impôt sur la fortune
d'abord je vois une demande de
démocratique le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et je vois une demande de
justice l'amnistié gilet jaune si jamais
on veut dénouer la crise si jamais on
veut continuer à vivre ensemble que ça
me fait pas plaisir moi que tous les
week-ends y ait des français qui table
sur 2 le français qu importe qu'ils
aient agi les jeunes ou qu'ils aient un
uniforme ça ne me fait pas plaisir mais
si on veut dénouer ça il faut sur ces
quatre demandes avoir des discussions
réel or la s'évacuer liesse f pas
question le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne pas question la tva à zéro
pour cent pas question et on va avoir
encore plus de quatre comparutions
immédiates pour les jeunes c'est pas en
menant cette tension qu'on apaise le
pays
il pensait que
le printemps sera chaud oui la mer grèce
comme outil révolutionnaire
oui parce que j'ai vu une interview au
parisien des proches de macron qu'ils
aient à il est au bord du burn out donc
ça veut dire qu'on peut y arriver bon
moi j'ai une proposition de loi sur le
burn out donc si ça peut lui servir il
est rincé les sauts répit ni surtout on
angoisse parce qu'avec le retour avec
les beaux jours ça va être le retour des
gis les jeunes qui vont faire des
barbecues sur les ronds points mais est
donc je suis voilà l'idée la merguez
révolutionnaire l'apéro facebook
il avait une autre idée aussi cessé
d'accompagner le gilet jaune d'un petit
jaune voilà voilà
comment va mick jagger ça va mieux ah
ouais ouais on est très rassuré en plus
la tournée n'a pas été annulée elle a
été juste reporté donc on attend des
nouvelles dates voix il va mieux il est
avec moi au coeur exactement il ya des
problèmes dans une valve le coeur c'est
des valves a levé il y avait eu une call
est plus du tout quoi conférer sa flèche
s'est effondré
dans sa flèche va très bien sa flèche
est toujours en flammes à
l'âge c'est pas ça m'a peut-être tout
ralentir ne s'est pas de comics va
pouvoir rpt chanter toute la nation
stonienne est fébrile mais travaille sur
un album alors vous êtes vous êtes très
très fan vous portez même des
chaussettes
religieux
c'est un petit peu le ko lagarde fun du
rock'n'roll vous portez des lunettes de
soleil on comprend bien ce que vous
dites
et tout le monde vous adore
j'imagine que vous porterez seulement
tant que tant que john lennon sera mort
voilà je tombe aussi recueilli ces nazis
mais vous avez 64 ans ouais
[Musique]
vieux qui peuvent comprendre c'est une
chanson des beatles à l'époque toute
notre génération disait j'ai faite
jamais confiance à un mec à plus de
trente ans et c'est ce qu'espère mourir
avant d'avoir 27 ans 1 c'est sa façon
j'ai dix ans ça me paraît fait peur
alors nous parlerons du concert requis
le chargement des rocky 2003 qu'il
making ville le 29 juin 2019 au stade de
france certes à 1000 mecs qui vont jouer
au stade de france ça va être assez
extraordinaire
et maintenant c'est l'heure de la promo
qui s'affiche c'est shopping
[Musique]
et
il
leur film à 9 rebonds soit retirée alors
mais ici ce soir pour parler d'un
relooking nil un concert au stade de
france où vont jouer mille musiciens
amateurs l'un après l'autre ou tous
ensemble alors d'après l'hôtel il ya
encore plein de gens qui ont pas compris
le concept est il y à des taxis qui me
demandait alors il y aura du monde on
peut venir oui vous pouvez venir c'est
ouvert ses publics et effectivement je
vais pas faire jouer 4 mais qu'après
quatre mecs 1000 ça serait on serait
encore la quête jours après ces mille
rockeur qui vont géant semble super idée
et le fait que tu es perdu le besnerais
soit pas
régulier comme je perds le brent et sur
whitney houston ne sera pas le gêner les
rockeurs a priori tu vois
mille musiciens interprétant le plus
connu c'est vous la belle et bien sûr
oui mais moi je sers à fédérer les
nations aura du punk qui aura du grunge
aurait dû rockab l'aura du hard rock du
métal en voilà mais
alors est-ce que vous avez arriver à
trouver de la drogue pour tout le monde
je crois que là selon la salle du tout
notre problème alors déjà s'il ya une
prise électrique
parce que milan
ça va faire des dribbles ya eu un
casting sur internet où chacun a envoyé
une vidéo et vous avez sélectionné 350
guitariste 250 batteur 220 bassiste il
ya soixante quinze chanteurs et
chanteuses et 75 chanteuse karité voilà
et puis tout le monde est au donc on
installe les batteurs dans l'est dans
les virages pour sonoriser tout le stade
mais 150 batteur d'un côté 150 de
l'autre et après on fait les 1100 comme
un millefeuille les guitaristes et
bassistes les guitaristes et bassistes
où les chanteurs devant et ensuite on
fait le spectacle tout d'abord un
batteur quand il fait un millefeuille
bref c'est plus
jusque là et on va jouer les grands
morceaux du classique rock pendant deux
heures voilà on a regardé la bande
annonce ok
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal
en fait higuain du viano l'informaticien
italien qui a lancé la faire pour faire
venir les foo fighters à cesena mille
musiciens jouaient leur souffle à 48
millions de vues sur youtube on regarde
à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
ça c'était la première fois donc aurait
pas de public c'était juste pour attirer
l'attention des foo fighters qui sont
venus ici d'allemands évidemment sont
venus parce que des gros l'aiment bien
me faire un peu le buzz et quand on
l'appelle aussi gentiment il a dit ok on
y va on va jouer pour vous et puis après
il avait pris le goût du truc ils ont
découvert qu'en fait avec des
oreillettes on arrive à synchroniser
mille musiciens ensemble et ça fait 1
sont fantastiques parce qu'il ya un truc
qui se dégage ont fait une ampleur
sonore qu'on veut qu'on ne voit que la
et du coup ils l'ont fait dans le stade
de florence une fois deux fois trois
fois hélas maintenant eh ben il arrive
en france et après vous le faire en
allemagne voilà c'est ça oui c'est un
truc qui va te donner un bain on est là
inverse que ça va devenir mondial on
espère que ça va des rendez vous ça peut
être vous réguliers parce qu'aujourd'hui
le rock c'est ça il ya quand même des
années qu'aucune major n'a signé un
nouveau groupe pour un nouvel artiste
rock donc maintenant c'est à nous de
créer des événements rock parce que
leurs hôtes madame encore assez de
[Rires]
l'amérique et l'ambition de rock et 2000
oui ça serait devenir pérenne de et
prouve déjà c'est de prouver qu'on va
remplir le stade parce que les artistes
qui remplissent un stade au monde y en a
10 y'a pas beaucoup plus et c'est un
truc colossal le stade de france dans un
métier pyramidale comme leur comme la
musique c'est vraiment le sommet absolu
et là ça va ces mille amateurs vont
devenir les super stars d'un soir oui
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça
c'est les musiques de bébés
space oddity petit bébé on va écouter un
autre
où
en fait râler
agir est de petite blague mais molex
plein oliver stone rockabye baby giro
que my baby nos ennemis ça parce que je
vais me parler du lycée de lille i rocks
vos enfants ils vont bien ils sont
fabuleux ah ouais allez je me dis
parfois je me dis mais qu'est ce que je
fais pour que je fais tous ces trucs là
quand je les vois arriver
dix au démon franchement c'est les
autres est petit rocker il mais ils sont
ils sont adorables vous savez quand
s'est marié le même jour ah oui le 21
juin 2014 avec la même
monnaie mais ce que tu ne sais pas c'est
qu'il ya pratiquement la même différence
d'âge entre candice et vous et audrey
mois oui c'est vrai ça nous sa nouvelle
génération
seule une seule mais c'est un grand
bonheur d'être avec une voilà une arme
qui me soutient dans ce projet des
manques en même temps que rate pas sa
scolarité à cause de ça
alors
finalement
in your life est-ce que vous avez été
plus sex drugs rock'n'roll rock'n'roll
un autre est mort ouais non parce que
moi c'est la musique j'étais venu pour
la musique alors évidemment il ya des
gens qui en venant pour la musique ont
découvert la drogue ou des trucs ils
sont partis là dedans mais moi pas moi
elle était là pour le rock et donc j'ai
toujours défendu sa essayé de me
bagarrer pour le rose pour aider les
musiques les plus anciens déjà ses
musiciens anglo saxons les aider nous
aider à les comprendre qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient qu est-ce qui disait que ce
qu'ils racontaient c'était des gangs
mirifiques on était fasciné par ces bad
boy des rolling stones moi j'ai isa bin
issa biais d'une certaine façon tous les
lycéens de france s'habiller pareil on
apprenait qu'il fumait de l'herbe tout
le monde voulait fumer de l'herbe on
était prêts quoi vivent tout le temps
quand on parle des beatles tout le temps
quand ils se mariaient je me mariais
quand il devançait se divorcer et quand
il se droguait je me droguais voilà
c'était nos maîtres une suite on est
tous fait quoi et aujourd'hui ils sont
encore là les stones et nous on est
encore là et c'est merveilleux quoi donc
ce soir le rayon de soleil d après midi
de france 2 le porte bonheur de delphine
ernotte la [__] du service marchés
pâtissent à la nouvelle je suis bien
lancée mais je continue la nouvelle
reine des témoignages de la télévision
française faustine bollaert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était bon là
c'était bon ils plus
[Musique]
on se rend ce soir le rayon de soleil d
après midi de france 2 le porte bonheur
de delphine ernotte
la nouvelle reine des témoignages de la
télévision française faustine bollaert à
l'époque
elle bien coup l'envié de jean luc
delarue serait fier de vous ah j'aime
l'idée j'ai pas s'il serait fier mais en
tout cas qu'ils soient contents que
l'émission de témoignages qu'il a mis à
l'antenne à l'époque ça peut la garder
le lien avec succès
mais pas user de
ce disque
est l'ancêtre du portable ouais seront
décrites et jeanine j'aurai 20 minutes
de retard
il arrivait sur la fin du générique
toujours on se demandait s'il allait
être en retard ou pas
alors tous les cas votre émission ça
commence aujourd'hui dépasse désormais
le million de téléspectateurs et 10 % de
part de marché c'est incroyable puisque
ça commence aujourd'hui
comment la réponse est en fait vous
devez faustine votre meilleure audience
à l' incendie de notre dame de paris au
lendemain de l'incendié tout le monde a
regardé le journal de france 2 et se
joindra effet 12 6% de parts de marché
comme quoi cet incendie finalement été
un mal pour un bien alors on a fait 13
quelques jours plus tard avec quoi et un
accident de car en pologne
ceci étant il ya deux points noirs on
les voit d'ici
d'abord il ya rex non payés on l'a tué
le chien
c'est sur la haine alors ne vous
inquiétez pas on n'a pas vraiment tué le
chien chien mais il s'avère qu'en effet
pendant un certain temps le rex sur
france 3 arrive est devant nous donc on
nous disait il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive à tuer le chien mais c'était une
expression évidemment s'avère que ça
commence à les retourner la nuit c'est
comme si bête ndiaye qui dit la meuf et
dead qua non et vous avez fait comment
vous avez dit que c'était pas vrai parce
qu'en fait ces chiens rex dax on est
vraiment rennes
on est mais oui parce que règle c'est
très important en racks en fait c'est le
quatrième rex ah oui c'est pas le vrai j
ai grand
rex
quatrième rec donc in europe tu es est
assez facilement l'autre problème
faustine c'est le bouquet vous avez un
bouquet derrière vous quand même que
c'est marrant on en parle beaucoup de la
grippe se boucler
peut-être peut-être un peu trop mais ces
progrès c'est le même bouquet de
septembre à juin qu'est-ce qui serait
pas en plastique le bouquet comme
l'animatrice
100% naturel on vérifiera faustine vous
n'avez jamais fait d'opérations si si si
si si mais je dirais voix çà n'est pas
les faits mais voici les âmes on leur
dit on a fait un petit truc tout de
suite tu regardes brun a non non mais
c'est quoi c'est quoi alors messi s'est
opéré des paupières ce que j'avais à
l'époque est tombé à
l'époque cela dit bonjour comment ça va
et où est un moment vous avez fausse il
faut quand même ok c'était ça la gloria
mais qui change ce soit aux deux
shopping bien avant ça commence
aujourd'hui
du lundi au vendredi à 13 55 sur france
2 ea table manger sain dépenser moins le
mardi 14 mai en prime time sur france 2
c'est ça alors on commence par ça
commence où les eaux commencent par cinq
en jambes elle le principe de l'émission
des gens qui ont une vie de merde qui
racontent leur vie à des gens qui
finalement se disent que leur vie en
comparaison est pas mal
ça cartonne un million 10% de part de
marché j'imagine ce style que par des
formations professionnelles vous voyez
les gens que vous rencontrez
à travers les thématiques de votre
émission désormais par exemple hyundai
ou systématique au collège été choisi en
dernier
quand on sait les équipes de foot je
vois plutôt dans les asexuels moi c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai j'ai fait une
émission je ne baisse pas mais je n'en
éprouve pas sa voix je baise pas
spéculer jack c'était ma [__] me sarr
je ne baisse pas
capice et en créole gemecs des couples
qui disent je n'éprouve pas cette fois
tu es célibataire
je me permets de te tutoyer mais il ya
des couples aussi qui viennent dans dix
ans nous n'avons aucune relation
sexuelle et ça ne nous manque pas et on
est très heureux très épanouie c'est un
je le recevrai bien volontiers bon j'ai
des ampoules aux mains encore une
thématique
une libido
je réponds face aux
talibans de football ça faisait 12 po si
ti jaune a dans l'idée de voir à travers
les gens vous rencontrez des thèmes pour
votre émission bernard campan j'ai
arrêté les plans à trois à 60 ans je
suis est plus épanouie que jamais sas et
voilà c'est un thème qui revient pour
elle pourrait l'être c'est vrai oui moi
je suis je me sens mieux à 60 ans que
car il était bien à 35 40 ou avantage
c'est que ça va durer moins longtemps
voilà maintenant ça ça va vite passer
l'invite way est question de buzz
un peu en ce moment c'est un peu voilà
jamais dit lundi les uns que steen
calme chez toi mais rassure moi tibet ce
genre de zinc a
déjà vu je suis pas tout seul terry wey
c'est non mais c'est qu'il ya de plus en
plus de jeunes qui disent aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont nos sexes oui complètement
on n'a eu aucune difficulté à trouver
des jeunes qui le revendique il ya même
des ya beaucoup de groupes sur facebook
des groupes de gens qui veulent pas
baisser quoi c'est un peu nos serveurs
de jinder les gangs nobel
où les rebelles aient reçu un invité qui
m'a expliqué qu'elle allait sur facebook
pour rencontrer quelqu'un qui ne
voudrait pas de sexe mais ensemble on se
pour être ensemble pour partager
d'autres choses mais je ne veux pas des
boîtes de non qu
alors moi par exemple ou hiver j'ai
connu l'amour à 60 ans ada complètement
le 2 mon deuxième mariage mama même
troisième à pardon là bas alors je me
suis je suis mariée trois fois le
troisième était le bon voilà c'est le
troisième comme les évasions de françois
mitterrand la troisième était la bonne
elle est plus jeune que vous thierry
cossavella quarante trois ans et ben on
peut faire aussi ce thème là oui voilà à
mon bonheur et qu'une femme beaucoup
plus jeune moins jeune énergie moi je
peux vous faire deux ans
lorsque ainsi ils seront une bonne
cliente pour votre émission par exemple
je peux vous propose des tonnes
êtes vous déjà tombée amoureuse d'un
membre de votre famille et ben oui
il est acquis à huawei non
car c'est pas mon père
mais oui c'est ça à quelqu'un qu'on m'a
présenté sur le tas en m'expliquant que
c'était quelqu'un de la famille sauf que
moi j'avais grandi sans le savoir et
donc du coup les amours se confondra pas
ça pue mari mais je ne dirai
l'incroyable christine boutin sors de ce
corps mais à plein de gens c'est
extrêmement commun d'avoir des relations
avaient battu les sages a vécu deux ans
avec ma mère
c'est un coup d'arrêt ma mère m a dit si
on m'avait dit qu'un jour je repasserai
parle
alors avez vous déjà trompé votre mère
avec votre soeur
faustine sur des tonnes d'essence avez
vous déjà trompé votre mari avec son
meilleur ami non non non je n'ai pas
trompé mon mari avec son animal de
compagnie comme vous connaissez mon mari
vous savez que
vous avez vraiment le gros lot oui il
est venu ici je les adore ont regardé ce
qu'il a déclaré dans cette évolution
magnéto serge on nous dit il faut être
comme ça fait un parangon de vertu et en
réalité on fait fi de tout ce qu'on est
biologiquement animal man un exemple par
exemple c'est la vie de couple on vous
dit il faut être mais c'est vrai toute
sa vie il faut être avec la même
personne fidèle etc on est animal n'ont
pas fait pour ça donc il faut faire un
travail intellectuel pour que ça tienne
30 40 50 ans étape amassé que tu avais
pas fait un animal man bord est là d'un
faux pas
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ce qu'il ose nous dire non
tout il le dit quand il et j'ai pas vu
ce passage là je vais lui casser la
gueule à la maison
[Musique]
alors votre deuxième shopping c'est à
table manger sain dépenser moins pas con
en même temps le 14 mai en prime sur
france 2 en compagnie du chef yves
camdeborde
cam de boire et une nutritionniste qui
s'appelle mathilde de tout vielles
chercheuse à l'inserm voilà exactement
donc l'idée c'est de faire une émission
à la bonne humeur sans culpabiliser les
gens pensent que j'ai décortiqué ce
qu'on a dans notre cas comme landon
c'est de voir à quel point la télévision
a changé parce qu'avoir un prime time il
y avait des girls et de l'énergie a
enchaîné sa superbe en acier était très
concernant mais bien quand on est dans
la vie on sent que son voilier en heure
[Applaudissements]
hostile au sol un seul conseil arrêtez
le reggae non faustine savez à quel
point je vous aime j'ai toujours soutenu
simplement un seul conseil ne retombait
pas dans la gourmandise comme du temps
de regarder
ses vaches c'est une photo en fin de
grossesse voix j'étais vraiment vouloir
arrêter multi de suite
m
non
aux platines j'imagine que vous
connaissez le jeu tu préfères on va
jouer tout de suite ok je la sttr
schildger
alors que steam est ce que tu préfères
présenter une émission pas coiffée et
pas maquillée ou présenter une émission
avec des vêtements complètement
transparent pas coiffée maquillée ab je
viens d'avoir 40 ans le corps s'expose -
quand même un au bon soin bas quand même
il ya des gens qui aiment le combat dès
10h
yahyavi jour j'étais dans un restaurant
puis un moment quelqu'un me raconte sa
vie comme ça la mort de ses parents ne
sait pas quoi et la fin je dl me diras
tu as réussi à me faire parler jeu et je
déclame fort tu sais personne ne résiste
je dis ça comme ça il ya quelqu'un à la
table à côté
karim et qu'idiot je viens voir la fille
qui dit que personne ne lui résiste et
alors je lui dise non mais je disais pas
ça dans le sens résine il me regarde et
me fais pas je m'attendais à une déesse
maintenant que je vous vois petit charme
sympathique oh là là on change de
restaurants violence et après il m'a dit
oh ça va te vexe pas on a le même âge
avec l âge 48 ans et médine
depuis j'ai décidé que je ne ferais
jamais démission nu puisque donc j'ai
passé là d'accord alors est ce que tu
pourrais bien qu'on dise que tu as de
l'empathie mais que tu as un peu con con
ou que tu n'as pas d'empathie mais tu es
très intelligente à jeu je suis
peut-être un peu con qu'on en fait oh
non
j'ai bien fait est ce que tu dois faire
ça commence aujourd'hui ou crier ça
commence aujourd'hui à chaque fois que
tu as un
orgasme sonore ah oui moi j'ai un
orgasme sonore donc la prochaine fois je
penserai à toi il suffirait simplement
ses voisins les habitants donnent à ces
personnes on est assez dense et maxime
jouenne tu préfère avoir le quai toute
ta vie
ou à voir cyril lignac qui te parle même
stop à l'oreille pendant un an
by mangue serré il j'ai plus de
nouvelles alors du coup j'aimerais je
vois là je serai contente de l'entendre
dans mon oreille un nom c'est lourd
quand même hein c'est un accent sur 900
on passe du temps avec cyril à la fin on
à son actrice et or et les arts dr c est
ce que tu préfères faire l'amour en
pensant à jean marc morandini
ou à michel drucker
michel de loin michel parce que michel
il est bien gaulée michel non mais cette
phrase
que mich et à l'époque à l'époque où on
prêt ou j'ai travaillé dans vivement
dimanche prochain c'est vrai qu'à la fin
des missions parfois on était dans sa
danse à l'oeuvre dans son bureau et y
retirer comme sa chemise moi j'ai une
verge est né et je voyais qu'il avait
des lave et des carrés de chocolat quoi
j'avais des bonnes tables
mais c'est depuis
alors est ce que tu préfères que maxime
chattam n'est plus de bras et un pénis
normal ou toujours ses deux bras mais un
micro pénis
j'ai un magicien des mains donc sa prime
instinct écrivains écrivent à ici voilà
il sait écrire des histoires sur mon
chemin en plus physiquement mais est ce
que tu préfères être topless dans voici
mme et arrête avec tes questions
toujours comme ça là c'est un marqueur
parce que des questions un peu tu l'as
pas demander si préféré avoir un micro
pénis mais quand je vais dans voici je
regrette
[Applaudissements]
j'estime je fais très attention parce
que je sais qu'il est ami compagnie
jusque pas en parler plus c'est bizarre
fossiles je reconnais pas on dirait
c'est la première fois qu'ils posent des
questions un peu perso c'est vrai que c
est un peu fort complaisent dans voici
où maxime avec une autre femme voilà
c'est tout un taux plein dans voici en
anglais ce donc là est ce que tu
préfères avoir des doigts aussi longue
tes jambes ou des gens qu'on peut si
l'homme que tu dois aller complètement
con cette question n'ont jamais rien tu
vas voir le prochain au fil de celle là
tu vois ce que tu vas y
compris des droits de douane déjà on
voit donc
que je réponde à cette question n'a pas
de réponse
pas avoir le ballon c'est tout voir le
doigt l'on a ouais j'ai un sens de la
logique très développée non bon très
bien
non j'ai dit on fait pas un chat si les
gens se caressent non semaine on touche
alors est ce que tu préfères ah là là
c'est pas une question de chad est ce
que tu préfères est moins rare de voir
un trou de balle au centre
deux exemples
non c'est pas ça c'est beaucoup plus
j'ai beaucoup moindre échelle s'est plu
à dieu elle kiffe et tout est fait
maison derrière est ce que tu préfères
devoir répondre à ces questions de la
mer pendant 10 minutes donc le baby
fassi fihri
ma naissance il est toujours là donc
c'est moi je te parle
car camille lacourt donc bon soit
réserves de brut et net il ya des
invités qui sentent le souple et à 20
qui sent le chlore
alors je rappelle donc votre spécialité
c'était 50 m et 100 m dos alors le dos
et c'est très bizarre parce que
effectivement on regarde le plafond et
on se fracasse la tête contre le contre
le record la position du missionnaire
ouais pendant la position du
missionnaire les hommes sont pas sur le
dos je parlais des femmes
alors vous publiez 50 nuance de bleu
chez michel lafon dont c'est une
autobiographie on y découvre l'histoire
d'un homme qui a beaucoup souffert
beaucoup souffert d'être en bogosse
beaucoup souffert de devenir un célèbre
beaucoup souffert de se faire arracher
sa chemise par des filles beaucoup
souffert et rôji de coucher avec 13
filles en une semaine c'est un
témoignage poignant dans nous dont nous
parlerons tout à l'heure enfin 13 filles
en une semaine en tous les cas ça montre
que vous n'êtes pas superstitieux non
mais c'est vrai que j'aurais pu
m'arrêter avant soit après mais voilà
c'était une c'est une parenthèse un peu
un peu folle mais vous avez parlé très
bien je trouve est ce que le record
était homologué
je sais pas il faudrait que j'appelle la
fédé il ya des bugs qui paraissent moi
je faisais l'amour uniquement sur le dos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
waka l'hymne à cô
champion du monde de natation mais aussi
champion du monde de le couchage avec
les filles
non non voilà alors vous publiez 50
nuance de bleu chez michel lafon le
pitch c'est un peu too much too soon
sert le sport de haut-niveau l'argent la
gloire les filles la petite existence
que l'on même la grande vie comme disait
paul mans vous écrivez je n'ai jamais
parlé de cette étrange déception à
personne la mélancolie du vainqueur un
phénomène de descente de décompression
comme lorsque tu remontes très vite des
profondeurs bref vous raconter comment
vous avez touché le fond de la piscine
[Musique]
on va raconter le déclic à l'âge de 3
ans à la piscine première fois je vais
dans les bassins trois ans gérer les
yeux bleus vous auriez les yeux verts
j'aurais fait du foot
pro qu il voulait aller dans les bassins
verdoso
ailleurs après vous raconte évidemment
votre histoire il ya un truc qui est
très très marquant je trouve dans votre
bouquin c'est des entraînements avec
philippe lucas qui entraînait aussi
laure manaudou c'est vraiment un
bourreau 1 c'est un bourreau mais c'est
surtout un acteur je pense que voilà il
je pense que c'est lui la star quand
quand ils nous entraînent et mai mais
vraiment sans son costume nous quand
aurez les caméras on savait que ça va
être super connard quoi mais en dehors
de ça c'est un mec adorable vraiment
très alléchant chez nous les achetons
nous nasa beth des cas les caméras on
sait le faire mais j'ai des méchants ils
pas moi j'adore raconter l'anecdote où
il lui firent d'entraînement je
comprends pas pourquoi il vient me voir
dans les vestiaires et il dit j'ai pas
été bon je suis un acteur génial mais je
comprends pas pourquoi tu me dis ça il y
avait ce que je pouvais pas virer lors
elle est en forme côté un peu fatigué
vas-y ces enfants qui sont interview
chez un méchant mais voilà donc c'est
vraiment
dans tous les cas il disait déjà 100 km
par semaine c'est à dire la besogne et
plus encore sa nana djimou a
pratiquement quoi ça va jamais compter
vraiment mais est donc là c'est le
cercle des nageurs de marseille et vous
raconter comment pour gagner vous
devenez un autre c'est à dire plus beau
plus forts plus intelligents est le jour
dès le jour des compétitions at which
est obligé de rentrer dans une phase où
je suis je suis incapable quoi donc
c'est vrai que je le raconte comme un
double un peu un peu maléfique vous
soyez tous mon contraire c'est un peu
détestable très arrogant très sûr de lui
et en fait cette image est importante
pour les adversaires et pour moi je suis
j'ai aucune fissure dans cette carapace
à ce moment là comme un même quand il
parle il ya des longueurs
c'est pas vrai c'est pareil
et le 11 août 2010 dont vous devez les
champions d'europe rétention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là vous devenez une star c'est la fiesta
les restos les soirées les défilés de
mode un jour il ya même karl lagerfeld
en personne qui vient vous voir comment
ces bases et j'ai été j'ai eu la chance
d'être l'égérie des montres de chanel et
donc j'avais fait un shooting avec lui
et j'avais été invité aussi lors du lors
du défilé et il m'avait serrer la main
un planeur et il est donc c'est un ouais
c'est un moment extraordinaire et quand
on fait de la piscine on s'attend pas à
ça donc c'est le karl lagarfeld et vous
devenez la coqueluche des annonceurs
magnéto cherche juste à lamballe en
valeur
le talent balle au bond
[Musique]
hamilton vale of
the economist a beau les fantastic mais
n'admet pas gc ca mr au
sénat m
je reçois écosse celtic
pharma sexuelles physiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment toutes les femmes sont folles
de vous en rencontrant bible et quand
vous êtes reçus par nicolas sarkozy à
l'elysée ça c'est la meilleure vous lui
demandez où et carla il vous dit je suis
pas fou je l'a enfermée à double tour
dans cette
usine
avait passé un bon moment et c'est vrai
qu'il avait répondu avec humour alors ce
qui est bizarre enfin si vous ne vivez
pas très bien vous dites je plais je
séduis jacques site génère des bouffées
de chaleur en quelques jours j'ai
l'impression que ma vie tourne au film
pour nous
j'espère pas pour lui mais pour nous oui
parce qu'un beau mec comme ça se serait
régalé pour tous les filles vous si ce
soit pour fatiguer deux mois mais
pourquoi j'ai pas les atouts pourquoi
cette période pourquoi cette place d'un
dictionnaire
c'est même pas une période c'était une
semaine mais c'était en fait je savais
que je pouvais plaire à van avant de
gagner et une fois que suis revenu de
budapest après cette médaille
j'étais devenu du gibier donc voilà je
vais pas m'en plaindre mais c'est vrai
que c'était une période très très
étrange en fête dans un bar et il ya des
pays qui vous arrache vos vêtements bois
et on venait de rentrer d'une
compétition et on buvait un verre
tranquillement avec les potes et il y en
a une qui arrivent et qui nous arracher
la chemise c'est arrivé aussi sur sur
fred bousquet pour un t-shirt 1 on était
devenus des objets en fait donc c'était
assez assez étrange et voilà donc c'est
bon c'est pas du foot natation ça
n'existait pas avant cette génération et
ça a été un vrai choc et là vous
rencontrez belle et lydec donc là quand
même il ya une femme qui qui émergent
que le dire au mieux au milieu de tout
ça oui bah c'est vrai que je la
rencontre à ce moment-là et de la vrille
mais une vraie histoire d'amour devrait
quand même différent de ce que j'ai
passé à celle du marché une vraie
histoire d'amour c'est elle qui veut
vous rencontrez donc elle organise un
dîner chez des amis vous y allez et
effectivement un moment il joue au blind
test et vous perdez vous êtes obligé de
d'enfiler la robe de miss france 2
valérie bègue c'est ça c'est ça dont
l'arrêt du défilé il y avait des amis à
elle qui était rugbyman et ouais moi
j'avais prévu de le faire le lendemain
pour être sûr de pouvoir la revoir
les rugbymans ils ont pas laissé passer
la chance de bosser vous avez oublié
votre montre a eu
d'actes manqués par ça arrive souvent
dans les faits ce gain
[Musique]
j'arrive aux côtes une bonbonne de
hainan a perdu des rolex
voit donc vous oubliez vêtements pour
venir là c'est vrai c'est une vraie
histoire d'amour c'est pas comme éric
lamothe une fille mariée vous divorcez
qu'en fait elle vous avez trompé avec un
emirati et vous l'aviez tromper aussi
ouais j'ai même pas envie d'entrer dans
les détails de sa mais nous oui
m sont les fins et moche donc moi je
préfère retenir tout ce qui était beau
on a eu un enfant on arrive à très bien
s'entendre voilà c'est lors de votre
fille que vous accompagnez la déconne
vite c'est mon seul luxe et bon moment
c'est d'accompagner jazz à l'école c'est
un rayon de soleil une petite fille pour
moi j'ai toujours des pères donc voilà
et pour l'instant ça se passe très très
bien avec valérie et aujourd'hui vous
êtes célibataire non aujourd'hui j'ai
retrouvé quelques uns mais
ça vous allez faire vous avez fait c'est
le challenge il fait plus beau comme ça
je suis sûr que ta discrétion te
poussera ne pas poser de questions sur
sept personnes n'ont pas de nom pas du
tout dérangé pas je veux pas savoir qui
c'est ça se passe bien très joli trésor
geithner même peut-être nous on peut
deviner c'est quelqu'un de codes de
commune voilà
maintenant vous l'avez survie de la
langue évidemment que j'ai vécu non non
c'est le blind test
[Musique]
alors le thème de ce soir c'est les
exilés fiscaux
voilà florent pagny oui vous n'êtes pas
exilé fiscal vous non vous vivez pas à
l'ombre pour des raisons fiscales non
villalon parce que vous aimez l'ombre
ouais comme l'a laissé savoir vous
n'êtes pas concerné par ce sujet en fait
mais vous avez quand même jouable en
test oui mais j'ai pas très bien nous
aussi on n'est pas non plus un athois
non toi je sais que tu es un vrai
français tu peux être bon elle aussi
lorsque aussi alors c'est bien non vous
vous passerez bien donc c'est très bien
depuis l'incident parce qu'on préfère le
dire je félicite
le vainqueur devra célébrer sa victoire
comme un joueur de foot qui marque un
but je vous montre des exemples magnéto
serge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
moi
donc d'un coup tout le monde celui je
vais peut-être pas donné toutes les
mares de sang mais j'adore nolwenn leroy
qui relève le kilt de l'homme et les
chaises mariani non deux poids deux
mesures c'est ça
attention broncher la guitare pour
chanter
on tenait de temps mort
moi j'aborde ma basse 1 2 twh musique
hamon
pas dans les dix pages regardez moi
garder celui qu'il a mais non mais
on veut plus faire un blind test tu
imagines que moi thierry ardisson je ne
peux plus faire de blind test parce
qu'ils trouvent tous au vert est ce que
tu en es ce que tu en avais j'ai une
musique un peu triste genre à la chaplin
non colson
o o
[Musique]
c'est fini l'amitié est lent
à
[Musique]
il va te faire un câlin
tellement aimé
je vous donnais
bien trop bien
c'est parce que
j'avais fait des yeux géante au caire
bon c'est des toiles qui serait ce n'est
pas que ces accords sont bon attention
laurent les joues un mot par n'allez pas
trop vite attention donc charles
aznavour donc exilé fiscal en suisse
plus maintenant évidemment
si tu fais les bains et lolo qui est ce
qui va lui rester quoi il a plus le
droit de vendre blind test à la place
des invités c'est bien c'est bien le
problème musique
autant à zemmour à l'idée est retiré et
que c'est pas pour nous
bravo
non
est ce là bas que tu dénonces ma fille
alors
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc johnny hallyday exilée
fiscale en suisse pas plus maintenant
c'est moche c'est non c'est vraiment
qu'après sa porte pas chance un nom
et moi il a chanté arthur
non
non c'est fait toute une liste d'exilés
fiscaux dans la tête c'est vrai service
d'ordre on attend service d'ordre est ce
que tu peux amener laurent hors de ce
qui
deviendra n avoir des constructions avec
sans déconner après tout ce qu'on a vécu
tu veux dire
attention rien entre nous ce qu'on a un
parti
unique
yannick doit
non
c'est le jv fiscale aux états unis
attention musique
là merci de penser aux
gal patagonie puis portugal
musique
patricia caleçon moulant
auparavant tu
sais quand tu vois
danse / patrick jacq sur quels efforts
c'est la fin du monde pour lui et bien
sûr le frisbee ou patristique et au
cannabis va passer les siens 15 h f
attention musique
[Musique]
dalida est morte pour traitement
écoute moi
j'habite en france
non
mais il est rentré attention c'est le
super banco
[Musique]
mais sont en france ça ça veut dire quoi
super banco à dire que celui ou celle
elle trouvera cette chanson aura tout
gagné d'accord
mais son titre en jeu 1 tu leur mets des
côtes est vraiment avec plaisir ses
connaissances attention musique fraîche
en contiennent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si ce terrain
il lui
faut quand même lorsque tu à londres que
l'on revienne vers la célébration oui je
vienne ici comme
ici à mener le moins ne sait pas faire
ça quand tu me fais rien
attention
ruzicka
attentif sur les handicaps tu peux faire
une image en amical je pense que tu
devrais aussi alors oui on est en
ligue 1
mais
pas si j'ai le corps l'âge de fer
tsa
pas j'ai pas mal j'ai pas mal
ripley et de rip
oui
les chanteurs
[Applaudissements]
là il faut se concentrer monsieur de la
villardière faut vous concentrez on va
faire un quiz à tout le monde joue
c'était un quiz qui s'appelle c'était
pas gagné jingle
[Musique]
vous devez reconnaître qui est sur la
photo voilà on commence laurent
verguet ch euro
on dirait qu'ils au
bac et laurent ruquier
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un qui a autant
changer si dans la belle et la bête à l'
attention munoz bernard tétouan terry
[__]
c'est moi évidemment il fallait 60 bis
et vit dans l'aude bon ben on arrête
c'est moins facile on y va non cash
money ouais oh là là
ça me rase que vous montrez là vraiment
il a vraiment évolué huit attention non
c'est un meilleur du
lot
[Applaudissements]
attention
et oui l ordre à ses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attentes et les points en géant
on rigole pas la ceiba gala attention
ma fille tom cruise bon
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il était vraiment mission
impossible
oui au ray johnson non
bien pharma non non non j'en ai dit
c'est une manne qui d'anglais voilà
qu'elle
s'était trompée s'arrête jamais ça
ça change aucun salaire
bon attention
ah oui je le sens ring et non non non je
dis fast elle en a d'autres
qui s'est fait raser la tête là non
jeanne mas alors on a dit sperme dans
les cheveux cameron diaz ouais ouais
le
chantier
lui aussi la gagnant bogossitude havane
à vous
j'en ai
[Applaudissements]
dit qu'en plus tu m'aimes bien nous
aussi on aime bien
oui quelques brochettes charlize theron
quoi
[Applaudissements]
jennifer ouais voilà là
bas ça c'est fait
bonjour joblot non sling ouais
moi je suis un laborieux mois
voilà ascad pire là je dois dire c'est
la plus difficile de tous le quiz la
mairie 16 agricole je vous dois me fixe
pas une politique sinon jeunes indices
bruce willis
et demi moore rôle elle connaît thoi
nhiêm il a tant
besoin
attention
bah oui là-bas mais là la patte de
penser du jogging
les gosses way we dance a mis en garde
c'est le principe
vous cache pas que 180 pas
c'est pas lui
qui a gagné largement elle a gagné là où
son attention sinon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
shy'm bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
shy'm ça vient de shay un adjectif
anglais qui veut dire timide et j'ai
longtemps cru que vous étiez timide
puisque au jour je suis tombé sur votre
compte instagram
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu un
peu foutu de nous au niveau de la tête
c'est bien c'est pas vous là sinon c'est
dommage
non mais vous êtes un peu foutu nous
avec votre humilité non non mais
regardez mylène farmer gardé plein
d'artistes comme éboue plein de
comédiens aussi pudique et timide dans
la vie et finalement ça ne les empêche
pas de pouvoir en montant sur scène et
support prochain non mais je vous adore
gérer ses photos on va vous voir en
tenue de soirée voilà et là c'est quand
vous regardez la télé maintenant voilà
mais c'est une façon effectivement pour
moi dans tous les ans ou tous ces
moments là td de d'exprimer ma féminité
et mon côté femme que je n'assume pas
forcément la vie de tous les jours mais
quand vous êtes tabbee vous êtes très
bien aussi un mail à l'armée - bien
peut-être mais voilà ça c'est le chien
de shy'm et elle s'est fait des bottes
et le chien
vous avez charme une garde-robe
incroyable on a des photos de votre
dressing
et puis après ça c'est juste pour les
chaussures là
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est cuit
cendrillon à ce que je porte la
maintenant dans une heure s'est terminée
ça serait beau ça retourne au styliste
j'adore le prince de galles le pied de
poule tout ça franchement on n'en sait
très bien merci beaucoup
d'être ici ce soir pour votre nouvel
album le 7e intitulé agapes et qui est
donc dans les bacs depuis hier alors à
gap et c'est le mot grec pour l'amour
divin
inconditionnels
l'agapé est souvent comparé à la charité
chrétienne dieu il ya des mots physique
eros l'amour de l'esprit ce qui entre
nous l'amour à plusieurs records
l'allemande julia et l'amour pour
l'amour à gap est d'accord mais
maintenant c'est un peu oui j'ai
réalisée au 5e pas pénétration
ces sortes de tantrisme wirwignes
halle aux toiles de maître la ville de
paris on aurait parlé d'amour courtois
oui ça fait du bien de parler de notre
dame de paris
alors il ya la gauche la vous revenez
sur votre chute aux ragots sur la fille
je te le dis vous revenez sur votre
chute quand vous sautez dans le public à
bercy et vous réglez vos comptes avec le
rappeur dems ont fait alors en 2015 il
chantait tu es passé par tout comme la
chatte à shy'm non elle la chanteuse
shy'm
nom est à l'achat de deux et pas lâcher
la capsule apollo scpa
c'est un circuit comme la salsa je ne
sais pas si c'est vrai mais je
l'appellerai au calme bon alors vous
avez répondu à l as tu veux mon cul à
faire la queue derrière james o voilà
roi mais il fallait répondre finalement
solution on l'écouté puis on n'en prend
pas compte parce qu'on a l'habitude de
prendre rien personnel parce qu on
entend tellement on en voit tellement
sur les réseaux sociaux etc bon si bons
passings de plus et puis au fil c'est
tellement gratuit tellement violent est
tellement irrespectueux que que je me
faisais mon bas voilà le nouvel album
sort j'ai envie d'en reparler aideront
de reparler de toutes ces choses dont
bercy également qui ont marqué un peu
les dernières années de ma carrière et
dames se faisait partie alors ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'à bercy vous avez
sauté dans le public est tombé par terre
je suis pas tombé par terre non non je
ne serai pas relevé mais j'ai atterri
très bas dans les mains des gens
effectivement il ya un point de vue de
caméra ou l'impression je m'écrase la
tête au sol mais je vous ai pas de la
rediffusion de la séquence alors dame
soldats habillés du polymère après il ya
une chanson beaucoup plus intéressante à
mon sens et absolument donc là avec
youssoupha et cameleyre c'est dur neuf
minutes et là vous vraiment vous parler
de tout là bas le même d'arthur ouais je
parle de touche parle c'est un peu comme
une confession à l'image de l'album
aussi qui est qui sonne comme une icône
comme une comme une rédemption où je
parle de véritablement en fait sans
langue de bois ou jeu je parle de mes de
mes démons des choses qui vont qui sont
moins bien et dans ma vie avec l'aide de
youssoupha le fait de ne pas les avoir
dit moi même ça m'a aidé à les assumer
et le fait que ce soit youssoupha qui
l'écrit laitiers müller sans me
connaître en plus en reconnaissant que
la femme qui voit la télé en voyant que
shine j'ai été très touchée en fait
d'eux
de leur compréhension voilà j'ai pris ça
vraiment com de com de l'amour et puis à
puerto rico donc avec vg de rim et ça
c'est vraiment idiot du reggaeton pour
le coup effectivement je suis quelqu'un
d'assez solaire quand même malgré tous
ses démons qu'on a tous j'aime je suis
plutôt optimiste et j'aime faire la fête
j'aime m'amuser j'aime danser et j'avais
envie d'en plus emmener cet album sur
scène donc il fallait aussi des titres
qui bouge quoi on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble mammifères
castro soleil n'aura que toi et moi
comptait pas pour le sec mais je te
salue marie reste un mois pour ça et
tout l'amour et sur toile à l'étranger
vous des peintres humain ça se voit
c'est ça une montée des tensions
ils ont passé quand il
veut mener à faire conduite ont
changé depuis
[Musique]
ça n'est pas à l'abri que ce soit un
tous deux été contraints des boîtes
série j'espère c'est penser un peu aux
vacances
c'est le but
tous les cas vous avez pris des risques
j'ai je pense que c'est un premier album
dans le sens où c'est la première fois
que je collabore avec des artistes que
vous connaissez les parties rien que je
ne connaissais jusque là bas est votre
bande way j'étais enfermé dans le studio
en éteignant la lumière quand vous
chantiez tout ça il là d'un seul coup
cette sortie de votre zone de confort
des gens vous avez découvert pour la
fabrication de ce disque absolument et
ça m'a bouleversé au départ parce que
j'étais encore une fois cette réserve
est cette timidité malgré tout qu'ils
étaient encore très prenante il a fallu
que je casse un peu tout ça et que je me
dis que si on timidité vous avez mieux
ça va mieux bien sûr mais je crois que
je vois moi parce que je suis pas qu'on
se rencontre ça va mieux
non vous avez déclaré saïd certains vont
chez le psy moi je fais de la musique
alors en faire le point sur votre état
psychique inverse une interview psy
[Musique]
je voulais tu me taux
mais pas beaucoup excuse est mégalo non
pas tellement cette parano non c'est pas
bien n'être pas nous la bonne c'est pour
moi me caler sa
porte c'est quoi les paranos aussi ont
des gènes by
jude et de schizo non c'est pas des
schizophrénies logan tamara sharif comme
c'est une forme de schizophrénie non
mais je sais je suis plusieurs femmes et
effectivement j'ai besoin d'eux j'ai eu
besoin de ce personnage de shy'm un peu
poussé à l'extrême 1 pour avoir le
courage exister de monter sur scène et
d'être exubérante et de m'éloigner de la
nana que j'étais dans la vie de tous les
jours mais après c'est pas de la
schizophrénie complète peut-être un
dédoublement de personnalité
hystéro à je peux
ouais jeune je l'étais fortement c'est
terrible mais j'ai d'autres abusé
comment vous pouvez vous voulez pas voir
ça bobby fait d'erreur et est retourné à
300 tonnes
non c'était physique c'était surtout
dans les relations amoureuses non mais
quand j'étais jeune annoncé sa probable
ouais vous avez vu que je vous parle pas
du genre de tenue merci c'était presque
bien je n'en vois pas mais là un moment
d'un faux
un peu comme son nom
deux magots
oui mais mais klaus mann j'aime bien me
faire mal moi un masochisme qui est auto
moto tour n'avait pas connu le sens des
tétons caja madrid non j'ai vraiment
c'est plus mental est un psycho
logiquement que physiquement il est homo
je suis curieuse mais pas mais j'adore
les hommes donc je ne préférais les
hommes à choisir sur chauny le désert de
porte avec un make way est ce que vous
êtes exhibo non on va revoir des photos
[Rires]
je m'emploie s'ils veulent comme ils
sont mais pourtant je suis comme ça
parce que je trouve qu'il n'atteindrait
comme sous mais bon mais j'ai trouvé ça
dommage kim avec une cible sur cette
bonne chose mais l'un talent fou vous
êtes chamallows
de passer la main tout en inversant
avait des mecs schéma l'os non j'aime
j'aime bien au contraire j'ai assez j'ai
beaucoup de caractère donc en face faut
que fonctionner aussi parce que vous
êtes gérant tôt ils s'étaient tous ces
mots ce gérant tous et les filles qui
aiment les vieux comme la femme de comme
la femme de comme un pou je trouve un
discret à tort qu'une délicieuse femme
et j'ai embrassé nous regardent jeu
j'aime bien je les aime bien tous mais
ça me dérange pas la différence d'âge
moi j'ai besoin de me sentir en sécurité
j'ai besoin de contiennent voilà quoi
d'accord vous êtes gérant peut aussi ça
ok je voudrais bien attaque avec kader
est de 30
ans et maintenant c'est l'heure des
infos 2 vise haut
[Applaudissements]
le monde
libération
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux venir au concert
c'est ça que je suis un bon début
je vous prête
ah oui j'avais eu
à l'écrire il toile est pas coutume je
commence par mon pays avec cette
information qui vient de belgique voici
donc les poutres que l'entreprise belge
va vous apporter en france pour
consolider notre dame de paris et saufs
vouloir me vanter je peux vous dire que
les poutres belge c'est du solide
oui c'était dégoûtant connaît
oui c'était ça tant qu'on est chez moi
automobile quand les belges eux lutte
contre la pollution taxant des véhicules
propres mais français
fait ce qu'on veut c'est une justement
jans puisque vous nous avez taxer la
dernière coupe du monde de football
passe pas ça ça passe pas assez sympa en
grosses sommes grosses sommes en
revanche une compétition mon avis vous
n'allez pas la gagner parce qu'on
organise nous la belgique à l'initiative
du premier festival de la coupe mulet en
europe lab on a un gros favoris qui
viennent chez nous c'est évidemment jean
claude van damme était mou oui il était
beau en france j'ai lu candidats aussi
bien sûr christophe castaner qu'on
attend vraiment à une belle place et
quelques challenger comme ce jeune
apollon voilà à ces mots sur sa coupe
et
encore un autre cider évidemment qu'on
attend avec impatience et lui
retirer moi photoshop
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie dans le chapitre belgique
avec cette dernière information à
bruxelles le pipi du manneken pis ce
sera enfin recyclé manneken pis qui a
ses fans notamment en france avec le
cardinal barbarin mais prêtre aussi
veulent tous des bénitiers même modèle
[Applaudissements]
passons à la france près de 700000
conducteurs roulent sans permis de
conduire et encore c'est encore plus
dangereux parce que parmi ces gens il ya
des femmes
[Applaudissements]
mais je les fais expert je suis
je vais me rattraper avec un article
voilà qui va mettre en valeur justement
les femmes et la conduite cette année
enfin un équipage 100% féminin prendra
le départ des 24 heures du mans
24 heures/24
ce sera plus les 17h30 le temps qu'elle
se prépare qu'elle se maquille caisses
vides
est repassé au chiraco chirac insert
pôle infos de la semaine elle a parlé
claude chirac la fille et elle dit en
fait elle se tapait le travail et ils en
récolter les fruits alors aujourd'hui ça
a bien changé autant c'était jacques qui
récoltait les fruits autant maintenant
c'est bernadette qui a récolté le légume
ouais ouais ouais c'est là je suis belge
et un cheval je veux je ne rends pas
compte politique internationale aux
rebelles en légumes à notre algérie
bouteflika
démissionne voilà pour la première fois
en 20 ans l'algérie s'est réveillée sans
bouteflika à sa tête et comme tous les
jours depuis 20 ans bouteflika ne s'est
pas réveillé
façon aux etats unis elle est noire
homosexuels mère de famille laurine
lightfoot est la nouvelle maire de
chicago et bien je peux clairement vous
l'annoncer il n'y aura pas de jumelage
entre chicago et béziers
pologne un des prêtres brûlent des
livres des sagas harry potter et
twilight je comprends pas cette haine
contre harry potter un jeune qui joue
avec sa baguette magique ça devrait
plaire aux prêts
allégé petites pages mexique pour objet
on commence voit la contraception une
pilule masculine donne des premiers
résultats encourageants et c'est vrai ça
a l'air plutôt efficace depuis l'entente
n'a pu eu aucun homme n'est tombée
enceinte
[Applaudissements]
autres expériences de ma appris
l'existence cette semaine la nasa
recherche des volontaires pour seize
mille cinq cents euros
resté allongé deux mois réactions sur
twitter et d'amandes michael schumacher
est pas renié voulait 16500 balle si
vous voulez je fais ça depuis des années
une
femme accuse son dentiste d'avoir
introduit son sexe dans sa bouche
pendant une concentration
heureusement qu'elle n'est pas au rendez
vous chez proctologue
je les fais rapidement parce que je
sentais qu'elle pouvait venir de la
scène je ramène plus la compléter voilà
sans transition justement les sondes
vaginale et rectal seront désormais
désinfecter après chaque utilisation
sénat c'est vrai toutes nos pensées vont
aux gens qui ont dû passer un examen
vaginale oreca avant cette décision est
interdite c'est de partir a filé par une
décision de justice australienne
apparemment péter sur ses collègues
n'est pas du harcèlement oui apparemment
c'est une décision du juge de paix
évidemment et oui bah ouais
et la librairie allait bien elle est
bien aujourd'hui
toujours pas retenu furent enclos qu
on va faire un truc ensemble
conso auchan reconnaît avoir vendu des
sacs banham avec une croix gammée en
pologne c'est terrible c'est choquant
fin j'avais comme 2019 on vend encore
des sacs badham
people
divorce au bout de quatre jours nicolas
cage s'est marié sur un coup de tête car
il était trop saoul faudra quand même
pensé à vérifier que christophe castaner
n'a pas passé la bague au doigt de clara
l'autre soir et après nicole sketches en
fait j'ai l'impression que certes il
s'est marié parce qu'il était ivre mais
je pense que son styliste a également
profité de son état pour se [__] de sa
gueule à quelques occasions
mode justement mba coronel la femme
d'elle chapeau créer une ligne de
vêtements à ça de lui faire tout bizarre
de créer une ligne combat passe n'est
fait mais je pense que tu jouais plus il
y aura de tout d'elle chapeau melon des
chapeaux hauts-de-forme de schiste
reconnaît
les enfants
[Applaudissements]
célébrée à vannes elle devait s'occuper
d'un cochon sauvé par une association
elle en fait du patin
pourvu qu'il devienne jamais famille
d'accueil
en normandie surpris en train d'abuser
d'un mouton il est condamné à 300 euros
à quelqu'un qui avait pas compris le
principe du jeu saute mouton d'accepter
va sauter au dessus d'eux dans
un malentendu sur une histoire de petit
beat fini en bagarre générale lors du
procès qui est une faute d'orthographe
et bien non évidemment ça vous avez vous
fait pas mais en fait c'est vraiment
arrivé c'est une voiture qui arrivait
pas à sortir la place de parking et les
gens ont voulu l'aider et le gars a dit
mais c'est à cause de la petite [__]
donc ils l'ont pris pour eux à cause de
l'alcool
véridique
véridique hiver et distel a valu un
tweet de christian qu'est salah qui nous
dit moi aussi tout le monde ment merde
pour une histoire de petit but
aller l'artiste la semaine à chaque
semaine je propose une visite et eybens
comme lara et là je l'emmène à bruxelles
je l'arrêt en main à bruxelles un
artiste belge pas si vous connaissez
pascal bernier il est né en 1960 et son
oeuvre relève à la fois de la nature
morte de l'art mortuaire et de la
taxidermie alors évidemment fait bien la
différence entre un taxidermiste et un
zoo film taxidermiste il pour un animal
et le bourg de paille zoophiles pour
l'animal et les deux bouts voilà
voilà et il a fait plein d'animaux c'est
assez marrant voilà ici on a un groupe
d'animaux qui revient sans doute d'une
manif gilet jaune et quelques autres
exemples c'est assez mignon voilà tout
le monde se rappelle de bibi phoque est
basse et bobo fox celui ci oui des
enfants qui regardent les photos de
petites blagues autre animal voilà ben
m'hidi 1 c'est un mélange entre bambi et
lady di
est bien le côté panpan cas c'est
amusant à ses lapins capter un coup le
fameux coup du lapin oh que oui plein de
blagues pour les enfants retraduit le
poussin le pouls sarlat qui se
débrouille comme il peut depuis qu'on a
annulé la vente de hicham chez décathlon
est ici de l'artiste avec une de ses
créations apparemment il a pris
l'expression balances ton port au pied
de la lettre
et aussi peut-être le plus mignon c'est
petit écureuil qui a découvert à son
insu bac une noisette c'est beaucoup
plus facile a réceptionné au pied d'un
arbre qu'une noix de coco
et plus surprenant une oeuvre qui
pourrait s'intituler accident de travail
pour rocco siffredi
ces cadeaux c'est pour crac crac ou la
ramener oui
y'a pas que des animaux de la forêt
y'a pas que les animaux plâtre
évidemment il ya encore
l'artiste lui-même pascal bernier l'a
baptisé perversion bipolaire à le
cauchemar de marine le pen un brin
calcul un blanc
alors y'a pas que des animaux dans
l'oeuvre de vernier et mais une passion
pour la mort qui suit toute son oeuvre
prenez ça voila voila c'est il a la
pêche pour 93 ans valéry giscard d
très intéressante aussi cette offre
parce qu'on découvre enfin ce qui se
cache dans le cerveau du créateur de
desigual
s'est lassé par jean-paul ce contrôle
c'est là
où ici enfin on a retrouvé les deux
premiers candidats de fort boyard et
s'est coincé entre des proc pas évidente
à l'époque alors que je vous dis qu'il
est angoissé par la mort il ya des
installations savas qui s'appelle
funeral tech dans chacune des petites
sépulture repose un appareil mobile ou
smartphone si on va de plus près en
regardant la dernière merveille d'apple
là il tombe j'ai perdu connecter sans
doute qui calcule le nombre d'asticots
les cercueils voisins et après que la
technologie regardez ici comme des
mignonnes la future tombe de patrick
sébastien parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
desserré au fond de cette boîte
bravo terminons par un dessin de pascal
bernier qui prouve que c'est un vrai
artiste contemporain puisqu'il n'est pas
contre l'idée d' [__] des mouches
allez donc le voir à la tête des 30
hambourg lison moreau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater le
dinar du tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu